y tras seis días de esta crisis
migratoria en la frontera entre
marruecos y españa hemos visto que se
han realizado las denominadas
devoluciones en caliente amparados bajo
la ley en el caso de los adultos pero
las organizaciones de derechos humanos
también denuncian las devoluciones de
menores se están vulnerando los derechos
de los migrantes en menores de edad en
las peticiones de asilo y como es la
situación de los que permanecen en el
territorio español
hola buenos días efectivamente se están
haciendo devoluciones de menores no se
les está identificando como grupos
vulnerables y bueno pues sabemos que se
han devuelto menores al territorio
marroquí esto evidentemente es una
violación de los derechos humanos de
estas niñas niñas se está contraviniendo
lo dispuesto por conozco es por la
convención de los derechos del niño y
también no se está atendiendo la
encuentra las recomendaciones que hizo
el comité de los derechos en españa en
el año
es decir el estado español tiene la
obligación de acoger a estos menores de
identificar identificarles y de
acogerles en su territorio y bueno pues
como digo lamentablemente se ha hecho
devolución de menores
y de verónica en la última semana se
estima que más de 8000 personas cruzaron
la frontera la mayoría ya están en
marruecos después del despliegue
policial y militar de españa para frenar
el flujo de personas quiénes son estos
migrantes que se juegan la vida cruzando
y qué es lo que ocurre cuando son
devueltos
pues excepcionalmente según los últimos
datos del propio ministro del interior-
más de seis mil quinientas personas
habrían sido ya devueltas a territorio
marroquí amistad internacional a lo que
ha venido a denunciar es que como no se
han identificado grupos vulnerables en
estos grupos y en estas devoluciones se
han podido devolver a solicitantes de
protección internacional no solamente
había personas de marroquí sino que
también han entrado personas de algún
país de áfrica subsahariana y bueno pues
en este sentido amnistía ha venido a
recordar que marruecos quien el pasado
amnistía ha denunciado graves
violaciones de derechos humanos contra
personas migrantes y presas refugiadas a
las que se les ha llevado a cabo
detenciones arbitrarias y se les ha
devuelto y dejándoles en el sur de
marruecos totalmente en la situación de
desamparo incluido también a personas
protección internacional e incluso
personas que tenían en su momento el
estatuto de refugiado
quiere decirse que marruecos no tiene un
sistema ha sido y tampoco cumple con los
tratados internacionales y no garantiza
los derechos de estas personas que han
sido devueltas
bueno precisamente marruecos es el
escudo en la frontera sur de europa
frente a la migración irregular que es
lo que implica esa externalización de
las fronteras
efectivamente amnistía viene denunciando
años de la externalización que está
haciendo europa de sus fronteras esto lo
que implica es que lamentablemente haya
países como marruecos como hemos visto
también con libia o con turquía donde se
están cometiendo graves violaciones de
derechos humanos con las personas
migrantes refugiadas y no hay una
rendición de cuentas al respecto
amnistía internacional está pidiendo en
ese marco del pacto de ver acción y así
lo que se está negociando en el marco de
la unión europea que haya mecanismos de
rendición de cuentas para evitar
precisamente esto que está ocurriendo
ahora mismo con marruecos